[Music]
Lindsay Lohan is totally trying to make
a mean girl sequel happen stop trying to
make fetch happen it's not going to
happen here's what you told it CNN
during a Facebook live chat on Thursday
I have been trying so hard to do a Mean
Girls - it is not in my hands I know
that Tina Fey and Lord Michaels all
apparent that everyone's very busy but I
won't keep forcing it and putting it on
them until we do it you want to do it
right I would love to I would love to
have like I would love to have Jamie Lee
Curtis Jimmy Fallon in the movie and
I've already written a treatment for it
so I just need to respond
I know Mark Waters is them it was the
director he happily come back for what
it's worth there already was a Mean
Girls - back in 2011 just with very few
of the original players involved
he called ourselves the anti-plastic Wow
that's pretty high before the facebook
chat
Lindsay opened up about her humanitarian
work on CNN on TV and I made a promise
to myself that I want to put my life
into giving back to other people
[Music]
you